[Music]
from Canon the studio behind the brick
and franchise the courty Cox He-Man
movie and the ninja cinematic extended
Universe comes a film based on the
completely made of fantasy of a con
artist named Frank dukes and it's
awesome this is exactly how I
lie about myself too
what sport back in the 80s Arnold and
Sly had the guns Seagal had the chops
but only Jean-Claude Van Damme had the
cakes Suit Up For What may not be his
first credited role but it's the first
time he'll play a martial arts master
from America you're not even trying to
understand what this means to us are you
with the loosest hamstrings in the West
hurts me just looking at it great for
rocking the splits bad for keeping the
beat
journey to Hong Kong home of the top
secret underground fighting tournament
known as the Kumite tomorrow we live for
the kumate I heard you can get killed at
that like I said a top secret
aren't you why is it that no one will
talk about the contact and you can see
me fight at the Kumite
I'm here too for the committee a top
secret underground this is the biggest
commentary ever we all know that the
kumate is happening here in Hong Kong
kumbage Express leaves in five minutes a
top secret underground someday I'll find
an equivalent chain make my father proud
okay forget it a well-known fighting
tournament with its own event staff flag
team and co-sponsors international
fighting Arts Association as co-sponsor
there he'll have to navigate a single
sketchy Alleyway eBay police were easy
to fool than an enter your birthday papa
oh yeah
shower
okay Frank you win and fight enough
Reverse Racism to fill a two-hour Tucker
Carlson rant why don't you quit teach me
you are not Japanese you Jackson
you look like a Jackson he's the
American who makes tricks with bricks
you don't look like Tanaka the Kumite
Administration wants you to be ashamed
of your heritage do they make Paco Rubik
and chop a coconut in half to enter no
yet Frank Duke says to perform the
Denmark Touch of death technique simply
for being Belgian American
meet Frank Dukes the inspiration the
true events of this film sure the real
Frank's military record shows he never
left San Diego he claims he sold his
Kumite trophy sword to Pirates and no
record of his Sensei can be found but he
happens to have the same name as a James
Bond character the ninjas worthy James
Bonds of Japan oh okay but that's just
his CIA cover story as we learn about
his life in an 11 minute long flashback
slash training montage that Frank wasn't
always a Hitman ninja who
secretly won the Medal of Honor he was
once an extremely slow boy
who got beat up by children
and was too dumb to know that San
Francisco Giants and New York Giants
were different teams go sports however
under the highly erotic tutelage of the
tanakas
[Music]
he'll transform into a shredded kicking
machine to honor his master or Avenge
the duty just met whatever Frank is just
here to kick some ribs and bust some
nuts
[Music]
along for the ride are Unforgettable
Side characters like Janice the love
interest and traitor because when you
only have one woman in your movie they
have to play both Rey the other love
interest if you ever need me I'll be
there I love you my friend and waiting
at the end of it all is legendary
villain Chong Lee a fighter who already
has his try again pose ready for his
Street Fighter character who's so evil
he tastes his own blood ah yes still
evil good haunts Frank's nightmares like
a raptor on an airplane
and purposely hurts people in this No
Holds Barred hurting people tournament
wait what's the matter Kumite crowd do
you like murder or not enjoy 90
action-packed minutes that let the
fighting styles Define the characters
lets the crazy faces do the acting
[Music]
and let's the sweet sweet music set the
mood
[Music]
because the last thing you want out of
this film or when they let the words
tell the story well I'm just trying to
be the best I can be not just for me for
Tanaka my shidoshi too go right ahead
right ahead end up like
worth
so slip into a comfortable pair of
Karate pants and re-watch the most
influential film ever made that's
responsible for those early years of UFC
before he realized martial arts don't
work Inspire the entire Mortal Kombat
franchise when the rights to
jean-claude's likeness fell through
and fueled an American president's rise
to power Mr Trump I may not share your
politics but I salute your commitment to
making people watch Bloodsport and fast
forwarding through the talking Parts USA
Kumite USA Kumite
story damn Yankee heat fighter
undercover bother Ghost Dog Origins
Sword Art offline apex predator Blanca
and these guys with one or two small
moments but boy do they make them count
mob guy finding a gold tooth
multiple threatening hand gestures guy
hey hey
kid cheering on some bullies and a
Bartles and James wine cooler shirt and
okay USA guy okay USA
[Music]
Frank Dukes has to think about his whole
life before he fights a dude
very good but brick not hit back meet me
in the Kumite
please get out of my Van Halen t-shirt
before you jinx the band and they break
up Cooper duper Pupa scooper the last
thing you made me say was super weird